but if you come with the right mindset
tonight ready to compete and understand
that this heat team's been playing well
this is a game you've got to win they've
got three starters out and you're at 13
and 18 coming in
you've got to
have a chance to win this as us haslam
knocks down a three now look i don't
know how many years it's been
since udanis has made a three
i was lucky enough to be as coaches
rookie year
2003 2004. he was a big part of
championship teams here
and five five four finals teams
when he was still playing in the
rotation but he wasn't doing this
he was at his best how about that that's
a fun
into the evening for this heat crowd
for the heat bench and for udonis haslam
who's absolutely beloved in this city i
mean think about this
how many times have you ever seen this
in the nba or in any sport
played high school basketball here in
miami miami senior won titles
his getaway time was he went to the
university of florida he took him to the
final four in gainesville spent one year
in europe when he wasn't drafted got
himself in great shape and now in his
19th year here at 41 years old
phenomenal career
phenomenal person and he just hit his
first three since the 19
2020 season
2019 2020 season inside